forget Footballers Wives wags mmm of la
or Real Housewives of Cheshire there is
a new show in town the wives of
Westminster no less are making their
presence felt this would have been
unacceptable to me at the best of times
but now a group of twigs Tory wives and
girlfriends have created an online forum
sharing tips on the latest 2000-pound
jumpsuits luxury properties and how to
avoid getting forward by brexit could
they be any more out of touch and it's
even more grating because we've just had
to enjoy the embarrassing spectacle of a
bunch of male Tory leadership contenders
parading their wives around as a key
part of their campaign strategies
Dominic Rob's wife was interviewed in
the kitchen Jeremy Hunt said his wife
was perfect it's all proof as if we
needed any but having had another female
prime minister does little to change the
fundamentally patriarchal nature of
British politics it feels like we're
back in the 1950s for the feminists
among us there are guaranteed to be some
truly nauseating weeks ahead so at this
stage is very quickly to read a response
from never know Bridget Nirvana bridge
and I should say founder of the wives of
Westminster it is a sad day for the
Labour Party when their MPs criticize
women for discussing issues such as
gender equality and the provision of
baby changing facilities for fathers
I've challenged their stereotype about
what according to them a Tory political
spouse is supposed to be the wives of
Westminster project is reaching out for
equality okay so I think probably we
should just just take a second look at
where we are in terms of women in
politics the moment so we've got a
female Prime Minister First Minister of
Scotland leader of the House of Commons
leader of the House of Lords defence
secretary we have got women in
significant roles in politics at the
moment so I don't believe that we've
retained ODEs of the 1950s and that
women are excluded from politics so I
don't share your view with that I also
don't think there was anything
particularly wrong with the interviews
that we saw over the weekend so I read
the one that you mentioned the Domenic
grab one and it was about four paged
interview and it was covering absolutely
everything from his parents his
upbringing his education
and indeed it referenced his wife and
how they'd met and indeed amongst other
things there was a picture of him and
his wife in the kitchen what does the
objectives of those things are is to
show us the the character behind the the
politician because one of the criticisms
leveled at politicians of all genders at
the moment is there at representers
they're nothing like us so I think
there's a real definite move to try and
make the politician more like ours and
more relatable to us and before I hand
over before when it comes to this kind
of wax of Westminster or whatever it is
wives of Westminster I find that stuff
bizarre I've never quite understood why
a woman herself would want to be defined
and identified as someone's husband
someone's wife I feel that weird but I
just think that we need to be careful
when we're basically saying that there's
still some kind of problem with women in
politics and sexes because I want women
to believe that they can have and do and
be anything and starting this as I
started this shows all of those rules
that women are holding and I think
believing that any women watching this
you can do whatever you want
III don't think that the way you
encourage women is by denying that the
problems exist I think you got be honest
about the problems and that's because
it's because of what you say Michelle
because of the fact that we do have
women in positions of power that it's
legal is that it's all the more shocking
to me that these cultural attitudes
towards the role of wives still exist
and I'll just show you what I'm saying
here's the oh my god shopping column and
this is what just fill it is this is and
I don't I love shopping by the way for
the record they just say something can I
just show you then you can come in this
is just who I happen to wholeheartedly
agree with on this she's responding to
the interview of Dominic Rob and his
wife look lo can we get away from the
idea of hot light husband as a prop no
matter how high I rise in politician I
promise you you will all you will save
my husband in Instagram hot the pic site
per favore and a full added as tracksuit
they immediately demands I delete this
requires some balance here yeah
sake listen here here just before we
began I said to you nice dress and he
said thank you that's it it's suit the
attention of everyone because you post
them on Instagram and you post the name
of the designer every single time are
you now drawing attention to your
clothes they're proud to support the
shopping thing they just put up it's
their choice yeah I agree with
everything Michele said it's like me who
stood as a Lib Dem Canyon complaining
about you know racism in they've got a
female Prime Minister complaining about
that when my own party has done worse
then let me look at that first seriously
I think also I think this is why after
well this is why feminism gets such a
bad rap because at the end and you know
no I'm with you on a lot of this stuff
but the problem with feminism is we
don't allow for balance we don't allow
some nuance at the end of day if a woman
wants to be a wife that's her choice and
the problem with feminism is we demonize
women who want to stay in a home yeah
and who want to support the matter on a
plantation of what I am saying no no no
what you're saying very is precisely
that but it is because that's what those
women have chosen why would we mind if
Jess Phillips was in the kitchen with
her husband probably not we would have
noticed and I think at the end of the
day there's nothing wrong with women
like us who choose to work and be
independent but at the same time I am
never gonna say there's something wrong
with a woman who just was and I mean
family up and say just who wants to be
at home and who wants to make sure their
job
she'll say no my father's on the shelves
took you about it's not women feminism
is about women having choice if they
want to say oh man it is a full-time job
to be at home then that is their choice
my problem is with the culture
underlying our politics when a candidate
feels the need in the role if mrs.
Johnson unlikely to support their
candidates their husband you're
misunderstanding me because I'm not
saying I have a problem with wives by
the way I'm not saying that we all know
that behind all these male politicians
often it is the support that's allowing
them to do the stuff they're doing I'm
saying well I don't like is the pressure
that I perceive that these politicians
feel they have to use their wives or
their families as a people saying the
Boris Johnson's fairly caught fresh
personal life is gonna be a hindrance it
should be tell me a lot about who he is
removing it tells me a lot about his
morals in a same way
yes it does I like Obama because he's
got Michelle Obama as his wife and I'd
certainly don't look at Melania Trump as
anybody that I would be inspired by it
tells me a lot about the man in love
because he's got this fabulous wife you
know why are we excited about Prince
Harry because he chose a very unhealthy
to be required to produce a perfect
person